la mort de thierry le luron il avait 34
ans le monde politique et c'est sa cible
favorite 39 pays se retrouvent totaux
groupe pour le sommet franco africain
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
côte à côte pour affirmer la place de la
france en afrique
la convalescence de renault avec des
résultats excellents mois d'octobre la
super 5 et toujours la voiture la plus
vendue en france ce jeudi 13 novembre un
jour de détention supplémentaires pour
les otages français du liban
marcel fontaine marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann aurel cornéa et jean
louis normand daneau amis d'antenne 2
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir il avait su
donner du talent aux hommes politiques
il leur en prêter leur voix et leur
verbe pour notre plus grand plaisir
thierry le luron avait 34 ans et 17 ans
de scène
il est mort ce matin à paris d'une
longue maladie dont il avait très
longtemps préféré nier la gravité pour
ménager les siens le luron c'est l
empêcheur de tourner en rond un monde
politique à lui tout seul sans la langue
de bois mais à béthune avec une langue
sacrément bien pendue
jean jacques dufour
le mariage courir quelques mois avant la
mort pour de vrai ce sourire qui vient
de se figer était devenue célèbre d'un
seul prix comme it's a good est mort à
la guerre de la grève ni les mains vides
c'est dubarbier l'ère de la barse
il faut dire avec un nom pareil thierry
le luron thierry le luron ne vous admire
il avait 18 ans thierry rey gouvernement
et moi-même
grâce à jacques chaban delmas il trouve
aussitôt et ses cibles privilégiées
rien les hommes politiques conseil des
ministres si vous n'étiez pas le
chanteur masqué il ne va plus les lâcher
je pense à peine un petit tour et c'est
un autre
je dirais que le président et moi même
vous me direz qu un retour peu ce sont
les modèles qui semblent limitées et ben
joie de vie je suis très content parce
que ses réponses etc c'est bon les
candidats aient vu parti communiste
ce sont les médias qui ont fendu il
arrive parfois que les grands de ce
monde interdisent l'antenne au petit
bonhomme à supportable comment casse son
miroir
les français feront assurément un bon
choix c'est le bon choix
puis quinze ans que je fais ce métier
que mes cibles c'est un peu le tir au
pigeon si vous voulez j'ai le même fusil
sceller les pigeons qui change
monsieur pasqua par exemple du rpr qui a
dit dans dans quand le point
l'interroger à mon sujet il a dû le lire
on prend les hommes politiques pour des
crétins malfaisants et ignare c'est
dangereux
alors quand on m'a interrogé là-dessus
j'ai dit que monsieur pasqua prenez son
cas pour une généralité
tout à coup l'an dernier au gymnase
comme pour les résumer tous sont seuls
personnages inventés de toutes pièces
glandus pourtant c'est ainsi qu'on le
préfère impitoyable
il faut tous qu'ils y passent aux aléas
auxquels les 1200 en 15 ans cet été
lorsque la mort s'annonce il fait
semblant d'en rire et la raison c'est si
bête de mourrir à 34 ans un commentaire
de marcel trillât les obsèques de
thierry le luron auront lieu mardi à
l'église de la madeleine à paris le
luron avait brocardé avec férocité mes
esprits tout ce que la politique et le
show-business compte de vedettes une
centaine de personnages une centaine de
voix et quelques milliers d'attitude de
tic toujours bien juger artistes et
politiques qu'il n'a pas épargné lui
rendent hommage ce soir c'est vrai
notamment d'alice sapritch qui fut
longtemps la cible de son humour
ravageur
c'est le cas aussi de guy bedos qui
remarque que le seraient bien méchant
pour les clowns cette année une
référence aussi à la disparition de
coluche il y a quelques mois
et puis il ya cette réaction de line
renaud dont vous l'avez vu le luron
s'est beaucoup moqué
ce qui n'empêche pas vous allez le voir
une bien jolie tendresse line renaud
terriblement émue à la longe tout à
l'heure de sa mort quand ils étaient
petits je crois que 7 par an elles
parlaient beaucoup de moi je faisais
entendre mes chansons si bien que quand
il avait 18 ans gt gt sa cible il
essayait c'est les gens nous croyait
désuni souvent parce qu il était sévère
avec moi mais en réalité ils
m'appelaient il me définis il me disait
assieds toi tu es assises je lui disais
oui écoute que je vais dire sur toi dans
mon tour de chant alors j'écoutais
quelquefois je vais y ait beaucoup parce
que c'était vraiment très drôle et puis
qu'est-ce que fuji si tu sais tu vas
loin thierry il le faisait il le faisait
quand même et après vous le regrettiez
pas parce que des espaces mal ou pas ce
mail où je veux quand je veux le faire
avec le ou enfin coûté c'est terrible
parce que c'était un garçon supérieur
intelligent et puis ça ne faisait que
commencer pour lui c'est dit luxe vous
l'avez vu tout à l'heure qui avait
découvert thierry le luron qui ne
l'avait jamais oublier guy lux lui aussi
très éprouvé par cette disparition au
thierry calmette vient tout juste de le
rencontrer et je les ai un peu inventé
combien de fois lui ai je dit dans ma
vie d'ailleurs on peut avoir nos
caractères on peut se chamailler on se
chamaillait sans fin dans la vie
toujours on sera comme modèle j'ai dit
toute façon tu m'appartiens peut alors
je te quitterai jamais et c'est vrai que
je j'ai une peine infinie ce tout ça
tellement qu'on a stage la perdre
d'avoir de voir mourir thierry parce que
thierry c'est autre chose c'est plus
distincts plus thierry je veux dire par
là que en fait les époques ont tous
besoin d'un thierry le luron
c'est un frondeur c'est un pamphlétaire
ils me regardaient à la fois les
légendes son métier
vichy passé comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs et tant mieux parce que ce
qui était oublié était bien plus triste
que ceux qui y passait mais il a
brocardé aussi milieux politiques et ça
souvent remis les choses en place
non une perte immense il avait une
couleur politique d'après vous il avait
toujours la couleur politique du clan
opposé au pouvoir en place je les ai vus
à la dernière du gymnase et nous avons
dîné ensemble
je l'avais vu sur scène y avait un chien
qui le regardaient gérer vie dans sa
loge il y avait le même chien qui le
regardaient gelé j au repas il y avait
toujours le chien qui le regardait quand
on s'est quittés sur le trottoir sur les
grands boulevards
le chien était toujours là le regarder
et ce soir c'est bête ce que je dis mais
si j'ai pas il semble que ce chien ne
sait plus regardé personne sait plus qui
regardent et le microcosme politique fut
un vivier sans pareil pour le talent des
thierry le luron chaban giscard
mitterrand chirac marché barre et bien
d'autres encore chacun eu droit à une
imitation sans douceur mais que l'esprit
rand est inattaquable seul explique que
les grands ténors politiques est aussi
choisi de rendre hommage à l'artiste
à commencer par françois mitterrand qui
a dressé tout à l'heure un télégramme à
la famille de thierry le luron il dit la
chose suivante je viens d'apprendre le
deuil qui nous frappe et les amis de
thierry ainsi que le monde du spectacle
auquel il sait donner tout entier
je salue son courage face à la maladie
j'adresse mes pensées personnelles à
tous ceux qui l'ont aimé voilà donc le
message du chef de l'état cette réaction
donc mais également beaucoup d'autres
réactions des grands ténors politiques
nous les découvrons maintenant les
français admirer son talent mais il
l'est mais surtout parce qu'ils
méritaient de l'être raymond barre a été
le premier à réagir à la nouvelle de la
mort de thierry le luron
sa mort m'a fait beaucoup de peine je
crois qu'il a gardé jusqu'au dernier
moment
l'espoir que sa maladie était
guérissable valéry giscard d'estaing
il était assez engagé et tout ce qu'il
faisait il le faisait avec ardeur et
enthousiasme c'était un homme de coeur
jacques chaban delmas
ces gens qui nous amusent sont le sel de
la terre dans nos vies pas toujours
facile
denis beaudoin au nom du premier
ministre il avait la dent dure et j'en
sais quelque chose
c'est la règle du jeu certains ne l'ont
pas admises
cela lui a valu une longue période
d'ostracisme dans les médias georges
marchais parfois il a dépassé les bornes
mais nous pouvons que lui pardonner ses
excès il avait le talent et la jeunesse
signé le front national nous rendrons
tout à l'heure un dernier hommage à
thierry le luron a fait qu'en fin de ce
journal de sketches 2 imitation sur fond
de cette cohabitation qui a si bien
nourri son répertoire
mais auparavant la suite de l'actualité
de ce jeudi qui nous entraîne vers
l'afrique pour le sommet franco africain
qui s'ouvre officieusement ce soir au
togo est officiellement demain toujours
au togo pour sa mitterrand venu en
guinée jacques chirac venant du congo se
sont retrouvés il ya plus d'une heure à
lomé nous serons tout à l'heure aux
côtés des 39 pays africains conviés à
cette réunion sur place pour la marge à
coubertin nous présente les grands
dossiers qui seront évoqués à partir de
demain dans ce circuit
accueil rituel prévisible les africains
ont le sens de l'hospitalité
mais derrière les sourires derrière la
joie l'inquiétude
même ici au togo la suisse de l'afrique
inquiétudes liées à un événement précis
une tentative de coup d'état s'est
produite à lomé le 23 septembre dernier
elle a échoué mais les soldats restent
vigilants et nerveux sait-on jamais
parmi les points stratégiques les plus
contrôlées la télé on ne peut pas faire
un pas ni vous envoyer une image sans
nos anges gardiens insécurité encore
plus grande dans de nombreux états
africains secoué par des conflits
idéologiques ethniques ou frontaliers
l'exemple le plus spectaculaire le chat
les dirigeants africains et français en
parlent chaque année mais il espère
cette fois incité les deux frères
ennemis beaucoup ni we day et hissène
habré à se réconcilier
sur les plus importantes étaient
représentés par goût lire
ce rallye un autre fléau angoisse
l'afrique moins bruyant mais plus
meurtrier que la guerre le sous
développement et la famille les togolais
ne se contente pas d'invoquer dac base
est le dieu de la réussite pour
fertiliser leurs terres ils font des
efforts considérables pour manger à leur
faim
ils y parviennent même s'il doit pour
cela s'endetter à l'extérieur
d'autres pays n'ont pas cette chance
par exemple l'ethiopie par exemple le
mali le général moussa traoré accueilli
par le président togolais eyadema
évoquera sans doute les difficultés
qu'il doit résoudre dans son pays un
seul chiffre révélateur huit habitants
sur 10 ne savent ni lire ni écrire
ajoutez à cela les atteintes aux droits
de l'homme en afrique du sud
et vous aurez une idée de la gravité de
la discussion qui s'engage ce soir à
lomé
ce n'est pas le fruit même exotiques du
hasard si ce sommet se tient dans cette
ancienne colonie française qui est donc
le togo un pays qui vous l'avez compris
entretient d'excellentes relations avec
paris
témoin l'envoi il ya six semaines deux
soldats français au lendemain d'une
tentative avortée de coup d'état qui
évoquait il ya un instant paul amar sur
ce pays qui accueille donc ce 13e sommet
franco africain
voici le reportage de daniel leconte et
jean-jacques le garrec la france au togo
c'est en régie vous aimeriez vivre là
bas
normal un rêve d'évasion et de promotion
agricole sa musique il la met la france
au togo
c'est d'abord ça et jaguar une armée
française qui survole lomé la capitale
pour rassurer une population affolée ses
hommes présentés à la presse comme les
auteurs d'une tentative de coup d'état
s'était en effet il ya six semaines à
peine un coup d'état s'appuyant sur
quelques dizaines de commando venu du
canal voisin objectif le renversement du
régime du président eyadéma au pouvoir
depuis 19 ans vrai ou faux tentative de
déstabilisation du togo alliés de la
france par le ghana du capitaine rollins
ami de kadhafi ou bien montage des
services de renseignement pour
consolider le régime
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'armée
togolaise faire tout contrôle de la
situation pendant quelques heures le
président eyadema est obligé de faire
appel à la france
c'est alors que 200 parachutistes du 11e
rpima venue de bangui débarque à lomé et
s'installent ici près de l'aéroport à 7
kilomètres du centre ville
en fait ils n'auront pas besoin
d'intervenir leur seule présence à
dissuader les agresseurs aient permis à
l'armée togolaise de reprendre le
contrôle de la situation
la france a donc rempli son rôle le
voici long trait à l'état togolais qu'il
peut compter sur ses alliés en cas de
coup dur
mais la france au togo c'est aussi cela
piqûre de la ville une cathédrale
témoignage d'une activité missionnaire
des produits made in tariff zoo
raffolent les coquettes une langue de
français langue officielle parlée par
tout le monde est enseigné dans ces
manuels scolaires que l'on trouve chez
tous les marchands les coopérants deux
cents en dessous qui enseigne dans les
écoles et universités du pays
et surtout surtout aucun complexe
vis-à-vis du passé oui oui
basso à la france la note au pire faire
un break pour les français
on aime les français et on connaît ses
classiques des guides et guider car il à
ce jeu-là ce molière
je ne sais d'autres gens france football
a profité de l'occasion pour envoyer
mots bonjour mon ami tiers en france
cet appel bijoux nous avions vont nous
étions dans l'amitié lorsqu'il était
enfant
présentement j'ai je fréquentais sur un
15 jours tu peux je peux le voir il
avoir en face on va revient encore et
souligné qu à part dont je les ai oublié
l'essentiel et celui-ci voie postale par
ses soins 18
lomé togo denis beaudoin le porte parole
de jacques chirac a répondu ce matin aux
trois réserves exprimées hier par
françois mitterrand sur le code de
nationalité d'abord matignon rappelle
que le gouvernement a tenu compte des
avis du conseil d'état
et puis sur le renvoie chez eux de 101
maliens il estime qu'il n'y a pas eu
violation du droit
enfin sur la réception de jonas savimbi
par françois léotard
monsieur beaudoin dit que c'est une
initiative du secrétaire général du prd
parti républicain autres du ministre que
l'état remplisse en vous le savez les
deux fonctions peut-être du nouveau dans
la sphère du carrefour du développement
yves chalier qui prétendent dans une
interview au point avoir reçu l'aide
d'un responsable du ministère de
l'intérieur pour quitter la france yves
chalier principal accusé dans cette
affaire serait prêt à revenir en france
écoutez les précisions d'olivier
dernière menacé par les services secrets
manipulés par les politiques
en fuite depuis sept mois yves chalier
est sur le point de se rendre à la
justice comme il le déclare à notre
confrère le point l'incarcération de la
femme qu'il aime l'a profondément choqué
maggie maquillant et
de la justice dit il on l'accuse d'avoir
bénéficié de l'argent détourné des
caisses du carrefour du développement
faux dit chalier pourtant cet
appartement du 16e arrondissement lui
étaient destinées l'avocat ligue schalit
est formel schalit est aux abois il n'a
pas d'argent
ses amis sont en prison il va rentrer là
parcs monsieur schalit réitère qu'il
compte se présenter à la justice
française dans un délai relativement
bref si des garanties notamment quand la
liberté de mcgee bastia qui n'est pour
rien dans cette affaire
et quant à sa propre sécurité lui sont
accordés monsieur schalit et souhaite
que cette affaire soit jugée sans
passion en ce qui le concerne il n'est
pas disposé à se prêter à une surenchère
de déclarations scandaleuses
il estime que pour l'essentiel les actes
qui lui sont reprochés lui ont été
commandés et obéissez h et qu'il est
convenu d'appeler la raison d'état yves
chalier a quitté rio depuis trois
semaines ils habitaient au 10e étage de
cet immeuble de copacabana avec comme
voisin de palier peler le roi pelé
aujourd'hui chalier s'est rapproché de
paris il se cache quelque part en europe
48 heures après la libération de camille
sonntag' et marcel khoudary les deux
enfin deux des otages français du liban
une interview bien intéressante du
vice-président syrien monsieur kadam
il explique à notre envoyé spécial
pierre serra que damas la syrie donc
entend bien ne ménagera aucun effort
pour obtenir la libération des autres
otages français
dans cet entretien monsieur madame parle
de politique juste et sage du
gouvernement français des mensonges des
britanniques est dit que les pays
européens sont victimes de la politique
américaine et israélienne
il affirme que les relations entre la
syrie et l'iran sont bonnes que l'iran
désire faire libérer les otages et à
l'intention des familles des otages
français il se dit optimiste toujours je
suis optimiste
nous allons comme j'ai déjà contenu et à
déployer des efforts aux libérer le tout
et je crois que nous allons arriver à
des bons résultats rapidement j'espère
pouces avec l'image de votre pays du
peuple syrien est même n'est pas très
bonne en france pas sympathique qu'est
ce que vous pouvez faire pour la changer
ce n'est pas notre responsabilité c'est
la responsabilité des mouvements
sionistes et des quelques parties en
france qui est non pas vu bien les
développements de notre région c'est
aussi de la faute de ceux qui ont pris
les otages tout de même nom
le trou connaissent bien que la syrie a
déployé du passé et maintenant des
grands efforts pour libérer les otages
le problème n'est pas le problème des
otages mais à déjeuner à l'elysée
la normalisation se poursuit entre paris
et téhéran c'est ainsi que le chargé
d'affaires français a présenté
aujourd'hui ses lettres d'accréditation
à téhéran où ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères monsieur velayati
une cérémonie d'ailleurs au cours de
laquelle le ministre iranien a fait
savoir que l'iran était intervenu auprès
de la syrie pour que sont libérés
camille sonntag' et marcel coude à
ronald reagan pourrait bien s'adresser
tout à l'heure aux américains pour les
informer lui aussi des efforts entrepris
pour obtenir la libération des otages
américains cette fois une intervention
qui s'inscrit sur fond de polémique
après les révélations du new york times
et du washington post qui confirme
l'envoi de matériel militaire américain
à destination de l'iran téhéran qui
détient a très probablement la clé de
cette libération
la régie renault va mieux avec des
résultats acquis mois après mois
confirme les bienfaits de sa
convalescence
dernier chiffre celui des
immatriculations pour le mois d'octobre
une progression de +2 8% sur le marché
français en émoi sur les raisons de ce
sursaut voici le commentaire d'alain
doubiste en examinant la r21 il ya neuf
mois georges besse pdg de la régie
renault exprimé un voeu aujourd'hui il
est largement exaucé
la r21 avec près de 10% des
immatriculations en octobre dépasse les
espérances de son constructeur la régie
s'était fixé un objectif pour 86 faire
plus de 30 % des immatriculations de
voitures neuves
l'objectif sera atteint même dépassé
d'abord la super 5 c'est toujours la
voiture la plus vendue en france 13 %
des immatriculations en octobre
plus que la peugeot 205 classé deuxième
au troisième rang donc la r21 les airs 9
et 11 redessiné n'ont pas encore le
temps de séduire les automobilistes
il s'agit pour la régie de réanimer
leurs ventes la r25 poursuit sa bonne
trajectoire avec trois et demi pour cent
de pénétration elle est quatre fois plus
vendu que la cx qui il est vrai est bien
plus ancienne
si on compare les immatriculations de
psa et de renault sur un an
on s'aperçoit que renault partie sous la
barre des 30% en octobre 85 dépasse
aujourd'hui les 34% alors que psa est en
diminution constante
après des années de remonter la régie
renault semble avoir pris la bonne voie
les ventes qui augmentent c'est le
reflet d'une image des modèles de la
régie qui s'améliore les grandes
manoeuvres de la bourse de paris avec
deux changements de propriétaire dans de
grandes entreprises d'abord les stylos
waterman qui sont repris par l'américain
gillette dont ce n'est pas le premier
investissement dans ce que l'on appelle
l'écriture et puis les huiles lesieur
qui passe sous le contrôle louis
bouchons qui élargit ainsi ce qui
élargit ainsi son assise dans le secteur
agroalimentaire la suite maintenant de
notre série sur la course aux prix
littéraires qui coïncide toujours avec
le mois de novembre après philippe labro
jean vautrin ce soir voici le portrait
d'un autre prétendant pascal quignard
qui publie le salon du muretain baer aux
éditions gallimard
c'est la première fois que cet auteur
plus connus pour des ouvrages
d'érudition choisi de s'adresser au
grand public son roman nous parle de ses
amitiés ses amours qui se vivent et puis
qui s'oublie un roman sur la mémoire qui
trahit les sens et qui transforme la
réalité
sylvie marion et pierre lepetit ont
rencontré pascal quignard
tous les après midi pascal quignard
entre ou 5 rue sébastien bottin
c'est ainsi qu'entre initiés on désigne
les éditions gallimard où il est
directeur littéraire
pascal quignard ne souhaite être filmé
que la dans son petit bureau sous les
combles
il ya chez lui une telle rigueur une
telle chaleur aussi qu'on est content
finalement de l'écouté simplement parler
son roman le salon du jour timbert lui a
coûté un effort énorme pour sortir des
travaux d'érudition où il s'épanouissait
auparavant la force protéger l'ère des
redditions derrière des haies des choses
un peu savant ont tout le monde de saint
girons centre-ville et l'âge essayer de
dénouer tout ce qui peut y avoir de plus
affectif dans lorsque j'étais de dire
que ce que j'étais ce que j'aime mais
c'est aussi à une histoire que vous
racontez une histoire d'amitié et
d'amour que j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à raconter une vraie grande
histoire que tout le monde peut lire à
tout à fait mais parler d'amour c'est
tous les rebonds sont les romans la
journée mais décrire avec des
personnages que vous dans la durée la
plus longue durée possible des scènes de
reconnaissance 15 ans après êtres qui se
sont aimés qui se retrouvent dans les
sources dont les souvenirs ne concordent
pas tout à fait dont même la manière
d'être
la sensualité les manifs sont en tournée
au cours du temps c'est un plaisir divin
c'est ce plaisir du roman pourquoi le
plaisir ne l'est-il pas en nous plus de
trace écrite il et il ajoute les succès
les épanchements la douceur la confiance
sont peut-être ce qui est le plus vite
oublié film dévoile et c'est pourquoi
j'ai écrit ce livre garder les traces du
plaisir à s'agripper un peu à la vie
mais plutôt que de culte de se
satisfaire des drames des détresses
essayer de récolter dans un livre tout
ski du mont et le plus le difficile à
dire et ils sont souvent des des moments
de sensualité des bonbons 12
chose qu'on aime l'écho la mémoire
visuellement laisse tomber les triples
est très très vite
c'est une question tout à ça ne s'est
pas très bien pour qui on hallucine aide
dans le lecteur qu'on se concevrait mais
en tout cas je sais pour ceux qui
m'aiment et j'écris je voudrais pouvoir
émouvoir ce qui m'a ému comme il m'aime
ou si je pouvais réaliser des notions
comme ça et faire pleurer par exemple ce
qui me ce qui par hasard mais fleury
alors la chaîne voilà le salon du
muretain berre c'est ce livre dont
pascal quignard et c'est aux éditions
gallimard c'est donc l'un des candidats
au prix de ce mois de novembre
après la page blanche de l'auteur
l'herbe verte du champ de courses pour
les résultats du quartier qui se courait
aujourd'hui à vincennes vingt huit 18 t2
qui rapportent dans l'ordre pour 507
1866 francs et dans un ordre différent
pour cette même somme de 5 francs 6 155
francs et 50 centimes et puis nous
parlons météo maintenant avec voulant
boussier ah oui et puis on l'attendait
depuis 24 heures mais ça y est cette
fois ci elle est là la perturbation
arrive attention elle est violente avec
tout son cortège de tourments de vent de
pluie et même peut-être de tempête en
atlantique pas de photos satellites ce
soir mais une carte du temps prévu pour
demain
assez tourmentée quand même avec sur
toute la moitié ouest du pays un ciel
couvert des précipitations importantes
des pluies continues et puis des vents
de sud-ouest qui je vous le disais
atteindront la tempête c'est à dire
force 9 force 10 sur l'échelle de
beaufort des vents entre 80 et 90 voire
95 km heure sur l'est du pays encore des
nuages mais un petit peu moins important
quelques précipitations plus fragmenté
des risques d'orages sur les
languedoc-roussillon sur la provence sur
la côte d'azur et sur la corse
et puis de belles éclaircies de lille à
perpignan des éclaircies qui se
décaleront vers l'est dans la journée
côté température paradoxalement ces
températures restent douces parce que
ces masses d'air viennent du sud est
ampera turquie alterneront demain qui
s'échelonneront demain de 17 à 13 et 14
degrés sur la moitié nord 14 degrés dans
l'est du pays et de 15 sièges jusqu'à 18
19 degrés sur la moitié sud 19 degrés
uniquement aline on termine avec notre
agenda de loi sera le vendredi 14
novembre le soleil se lèvera à 7h59
se couchera à 17h11 trois minutes de
soleil en moins ce sera la sainte
sidonie mais ce sera aussi la sainte
philomène la sainte philomène une fête
que l'on souhaite un peu moins souvent
avant de nous quitter un dernier hommage
vous l'avais dit à thierry le luron
antenne 2 je dois vous dire d'abord
modifiera ses programmes samedi soir
avec une émission spéciale ce sera juste
avant champs elysées mais dès ce soir
nous retrouvons thierry pour un court
moment avec deux sketches d'actualité
juste le temps de vous dire que le
dernier journal est à 23h45 et que le
magazine de la rédaction est à 22h35
qu'il est présenté par daniel bilalian
tout de suite
thierry le luron bonsoir demain 20
heures
vous avez vos deux moutons oui pour
d'autres en armes
william f combat où crèchent ça pour
trouver leurs noms
j'ai tout vu si dell mais moi je peu
près tous ceux qui croient qu'ils ont la
foi dans le celi ch
car voyez-vous mes bien chers frères sur
gtv dans unique only
proposé à catherine dufour livre le
rouge le noir a dit que vous étiez un
homme secret un homme que personne ne
connaissait c'est nous je mets moi-même
je n'ai pas très bien vous demanderiez
ce que je vais faire mais pour la france
demain
mes amis chers compagnons le problème de
la natalité en france se pose avec
acuité et je dirais il faut faire des
enfants sur une grande échelle louis des
enfants qui rejoindront le rpr et ses
jeunes
charpy pons l'abbé pasqua couve de
murville c'est perdreau de l'année qui
en 40 ans - quarante ans de maison bien
sûr et alors là croyez moi mes amis au
rpr ce sera tout bon